I think it’s okay with a little wind.
It’s kind of blustery in the fall and that’s
nice.
Hi, my name is Corey D’Augustine from the
IN THE STUDIO series here at MoMA.
I want to welcome you back to the Museum.
In fact, we’re in the Sculpture Garden today.
Hope everyone had a great summer.
It’s definitely fall here in New York.
It’s kind of cool and windy and drizzly—you
can probably tell here.
School is back in session, and just want to
let you know how we’ll be starting that
off next Thursday, September 14, 3:00 p.m.
New York time, we will have our second live
Q&A session.
We’ve had some great questions over the
past couple months.
We’ll be addressing a lot of those.
Also please feel free to leave questions down
below on this video, and in addition we’ll
be taking live questions of course.
We’ll have some announcements about additional
IN THE STUDIO videos that are coming your
way.
And please be sure to click SUBSCRIBE below
so you don’t miss any of those episodes.
Again, that’s Thursday, September 14 at
3:00 p.m. East Coast time (New York time).
Looking forward to seeing you then!